JENNY BROWN: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2019,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
Building sustainability
into our infrastructure,
your goals and new products,
then stay tuned because
here's the Rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You might be familiar
with Google's commitment
to organizing the
world's information
and making it useful and
accessible but few know
about Google's equally
aggressive goals
around sustainability.
For example, Google is
using machine learning
to predict wind power up
to 36 hours in advance,
turning it into a financially
viable renewable energy
source that helps
power our data centers.
In fact, Google data
centers are carbon neutral,
meaning that anyone
who's using Google Cloud
is contributing toward their
own company's sustainability
targets.
So let's take a look at
two of those companies
and see how they're partnering
with Google to supercharge
those efforts.
National Geographic
Partners seeks
to inspire users to care about
and advocate for sustainability
with their content.
In keeping with their efforts
to be environmentally conscious,
they moved over their
entire image collection
to Google Cloud.
In their talk, the VP of
digital products and e-commerce
goes into detail about how they
plan to expand this initiative.
SunPower makes the world's
most efficient solar cells
and panels for commercial
and residential use.
They're even used by
Google's Project Loon.
Because solar power design
is a complicated process,
it would take them a
century to roll out
SunPower to all American
businesses and homes.
But with Google Sunroom, Maps
data, and Google Cloud Machine
Learning, SunPower is
launching a program
that can create the same design
quote in only 60 seconds.
These and other
sustainability efforts
have led to some incredible
achievements that
support our planet and we're
excited to pass them down
to our customers.
If you'd like to
see the full talk
and learn more about
environmental programs I
mentioned, check out the link
in the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]